[Música]
oye te gustaría entrenar kickboxing y yo
me quedé pensando un poco y como había
visto algunas películas de equivoquen
con mi papá le dije si no me dice vamos
el sábado pero era un miércoles y me
dijo vamos el sábado le dije porque
amigo que mañana miércoles mañana jueves
mañana ya voy a entrenar dije bueno
vamos el sábado ya fuimos el sábado era
una clase mixta fue mi hermana fue mi
mamá y fui yo y ya pues fui como me
dijeron una playa blanca un short negro
y ahí estaba pues me dieron su mejor
ejemplo de trabajo duro de esfuerzo
y de disfrutar lo que íbamos a hacer
pues a partir de ese día no he dejado de
entrenar artes marciales
es mi pasión me apasionó mucho
y pues
sigo disfrutando cada viaje entreno y
sigo con esos buenos ejemplos de mi
familia
entonces una vez y ya empecé a entrenar
verdad diario ya iba yo a mis horarios
de entrenamiento y una vez vi que unos
chavos estaban preparando nuestra
mascota tiene mi edad yo empecé en la
pubertad tenía 13 14 años y vi que unos
chavos estaban entrenando para
prepararte para una pelea y yo me les
quedaba viendo y todo bueno llegó la
fecha en la que esos chavos iban a
pelear y
ya pues yo mi mamá que yo estaba muy
entusiasmado como que quería y le dije
mamá puedo ir y pero pues sabíamos que
estaba difícil verdad porque yo tienen
su responsabilidad de sus compromisos
mis padres y pues un chavo me dijo
quiere decir este si quieres vamos
estábamos acciones y yo le digo a tu
mamá y ya le dije es bueno y pues nos
organizamos y fui pues bien esa pelea yo
me sentí tan nervioso como si yo fuera
el que estuviera ahí peleando
a juicio dije dentro de mí se me dio la
idea de quiero pelear un día
después de eso que quise pelear un día
le dije al entrenador oiga entrenador
este yo quiero / no yo quiero pelear un
día y me dice bueno te voy a tomar en
cuenta apunta que en esta libreta y
cuando salga un evento pesatti y
recuerde cuando algún evento pues ya voy
a ver tu peso y yo ay te metemos y le
dije bueno ya me anoté y todo y si me
puse un poco nervioso verdad porque es
un compromiso entonces pues sale la
pelea
tenía un s
tenía el ejemplo verdad de entrenar duro
y sobre todo algo me hacía a mí apoyarme
los entrenadores este era un no sé algo
que decía pasar me apoyó en los
entrenadores verdad entonces fianza
pelea y entrené muy fuerte pero también
me apoyan los entrenadores entonces yo
creía que iba fuerte e inteligente
y lleva el día de la pelea ya pues días
antes yo estaba pensando como bien
trabajar qué voy a hacer hasta que me
voy a poner y todo
y ya estoy calentando verdad para entrar
pelear y estoy bien nervioso que voy al
baño y que todo entonces este
ya estoy arriba del ring y digo que
estoy haciendo aquí
y dijo
se me vino a la mente fuerte y luego
pues siguiente creo que entrena
inteligente aparte todas las áreas
entonces vamos a darle y ya vi a mi
oponente que estaba listo y calentar
como para contra mí y pero yo también y
ya vivimos y gracias a dios y al trabajo
duro y al trabajo inteligente ganamos
esa pelea
y ahí empezamos
y pues pero también gracias al apoyo de
mis padres
y entonces este
yo quería volver a pelear aunque yo
sentía esos nervios de que estoy
haciendo aquí y que todos los nervios
que sentí yo quería volver a pelear ya
quería volverlo a hacer y llevo en el
entrenador y otra vez y ya me vuelvo a
notar y le pongo mi peso y todo sale
otra oportunidad y empezar a pelear y
volvió a pelear bueno yo conocí a la
constancia
sin quererlo pues era el inicio de mi
carrera y trabajando duro trabajando
inteligente y siendo constante me
posicione entre los mejores peleadores
del país había pelado en todo méxico
contra los mejores peleadores contra
entrenadores y yo apenas pues iba a
tener 22 23 años pero yo creía que si
entrenaba duro y entrenaba inteligente
verdad
y voy a llegar seguro más que confiado
seguro yo también confiaba empecé en mi
verdad en que sí podemos
y junto con la constancia pues entonces
nos posicionamos en los mejores
peleadores del país pero todo fue porque
pues después de una vez quiero pelear
amateur ya que se pelea profesional y
los nervios eran los mismos que encontró
uno de muay thai y que el que esté pues
salta con la rodilla así que con los
codos y violencia yoshito cuídame por
favor y cuidarlo también a él pero yo
voy a dar todo
y darle la victoria por favor
ips
este y pues peleamos entonces en todo
méxico y todo pero
pues
pelea tras pelea turbo gane muchas
peleas gracias a dios el trabajo duro
trabajo inteligente a la constancia dan
en muchas peleas y perdí algunas ya es
pesaba yo a conocer allí y se me viene a
la mente la perseverancia porque pues
perdí alguna pelea y dije no ve ni modo
que aquí ya no ya no peleé por qué
perdió esta pelea no pues pues aparte ya
me gustaba que ya empezaba a ganar
dinero que eso que me gustaba me gustaba
pelear ya empezaban a pagar nos pagaban
mucho y algunas perlas me gana pagar
nada más mil pesos verdad y yo hacía
todo un entrenamiento de 23 meses verdad
pero me gustaba
entonces aquí voy a pelear ya quería yo
también un mejor sueldo y pues ya quería
pelear en la mejor empresa de méxico
cuando después de pelear profesionales
quería pelear en la mejor empresa es
lógico en la que la mejor empresa en
méxico
y gracias a dios se oyó la oportunidad
también pues ahí ya estando en pues lo
mejor de méxico durante muchas peleas
también perdí algunas y la perseverancia
pues si me impulsaba a seguir y a seguir
bueno pues ya éste
hay un cierto ritmo la verdad pero
había una promotora hay una promotora
que es la mejor de todo el mundo y se
llama vfc
entonces me metí a la idea se metió a la
casa se metió la idea se metió a la
cabeza el poder es verdad pero pelear yo
96 yo creía que yo si podía yo venir a
los peleadores de ufc dije es que yo
creo que si puedo y luego un amigo me
invitó una vez a comer a su casa y me
puso unas peleas y habíamos de limpieza
apenas estaban entrando los de mi
categoría este porque yo creo que esta
categoría es de mexico 135 libras pues
porque me gusta nuestra complexión
verdad bueno por la mía
y ya está
me dice cómo ves al xxi le da soledad
yo le dije pues yo creo que sí verdad yo
creo que sí yo creo que sí puedo pues
bueno sí
y pues le seguí
y ya una vez esté
pues
ya yo estaba en un trabajo estable
porque necesitaba y tenía mi novia y la
que era invitada al cine y todo y al
invitarla a cenar y también pues quería
ayudar a mis padres a mis hermanos
verdad pero éste se metió esa idea a la
cabeza de pelear en ufc pero era muy
difícil para mí yo no tenía visa verdad
y pues mi trabajo ya había entrado a una
tienda departamental en la cual pues era
donde yo hogar podía tener una mejor
estabilidad económica pero por azares
del destino
yo ya no entraba georgia no entrenaba en
una academia yo ya me había
independizado yo ya estaba dando clases
en un gimnasio tenía tres trabajos el
primero era a través de la tienda
departamental que era en la que me daba
más estabilidad económica y luego yo
daba clases en un gimnasio saliendo a
trabajar y luego yo me seguía preparando
en mi carrera porque seguía con mi idea
de llegar a ufc que se podía ver como no
sabía pero tal vez y pues pero está muy
lejos la idea pero una vez
este pez de penséis me de mojado y
muchas cosas verdad pero una vez
escuché una noticia que ufc pone los los
ojos en méxico va a ser un casting en el
que se van a llevar a 8 peleadores
becados al que les entonces será el
mejor gimnasio del mundo
y pues si me emocioné y este y dije esta
es mi oportunidad yo estaba entre los
mejores peleadores de medios ya había
peleado contra todos entonces pues si
puedo y pues ojalá y me lleven
me dije pero tengo que hacer algo tengo
que hacer algo bien trabajar muy duro
voy a trabajar inteligente renunciar al
trabajo que me daba más estabilidad
económica pero no me pesaba mucho porque
yo creía que si podía llegar a ufc pero
de todo nada más tenía gas para mis
gastos verdad y pues el apoyo de mi
novio de mis padres todo es lo que me
hacía fuerte
entonces yo me preparo de nuestro
trabajo me preparo todo el día me
preparo todos los días todo lo que hacía
todo era relacionado a las artes
marciales y dormía era para descansar y
estar en óptimas condiciones si comía
muy bien para ponerme más fuerte y si
entrenaba ahora para estar bien
preparado entonces yo creía que es que
me sentía listo y llego al casting doy
lo mejor de mí consistía en que nos
pedían golpes para ver nuestra técnica y
nos ponían a un combate al cuerpo a
cuerpo con algún otro peleador al azar
pues hago lo mejor que yo puedo en la
técnica y en el combate del cuerpo
cuerpo fueron dos minutos en la prisión
un peleador que también tenía esta
experiencia y yo ya lo conocía de que me
lo había escuchado
pues doy lo mejor de mí y lo lindo y yo
dije tal vez si quedó tal vez es que él
pues ya estaba yo así
estaba sí verdad ya terminan terminan el
casting ya nos dicen a todos oigan este
muchas gracias por participar y éste les
vamos a hablar por teléfono hayan
quedado no hayan quedado lo más
agradecido por su por estar aquí y
también o si no pero les vamos a pedir
todos los documentos necesarios para que
vayamos a la vez
pues ya me fui a mi casa y yo les
preguntaba a los que yo conocía cómo me
viste y todos decían pues bien yo creo
que si es también tu récord y todo
desear pues ojalá primero dios y pues no
quede
h
y este
pues ya después me enteré que yo ya
habías porque en mente el que no quede
porque ya que ya estaban los otros
chavos que se iban a llevar pero a mí no
me habían hablado ni para darle gracias
ni nada
hasta que después cuando alejandro y yo
yo estaba esperando esa llamada muchos
amigos me dicen oye que te esté
bajo y sigue entrenando no te desanimes
está hecha de ganas
no se preocupen y muchas gracias porque
ya esté
pues ya llegó a mi casa seguir peleando
y siguió entrenando y seguir peleando y
me concentre más en dar clases pues
tener a chavos que me exijan más a ser
mejor y todo estaba entrenando a cinco
chavos que daban lo mejor de si estaban
comprometidos con ellos y yo estaba
comprometido con ellos también en
ayudarlos y dar lo mejor de mí y luego
por azares del destino pierdo una pelea
y lo digo no pues es que ya se me hace
que lo que voy a hacer es mejor dedicar
al 100% estos chavos que estoy
entrenando porque me están dando lo
mejor de ellos y me voy a mejor si no
llega un golpe si yo tenía como 24 años
si yo no si éste si yo no llegué a ufc
voy a llevar a alguien la web pc
y pues ya apenas estamos en eso estaba
diciendo que como ven que yo estaba
mandando correos y mensajes a todos los
que conocía con los que peleaba de las
promotoras que yo conocía que había
peleado oigan este
si ocupan algún chavo de este peso de
aquí tengo estos están comprometidos son
muy buenos y todo eso y uno de ellos era
un entrenador de tijuana y me dice oye
pero como que tú ya te vas a retirar si
todavía estás muy joven y aparte de todo
pues todo ya puedes cumplir tus sueños
si tú quieres verdad porque yo le había
practicado alguna vez que le llegan un
pc y me dice mira yo te puedo ofrecer
que te vengas aquí a mi gimnasio verdad
tenemos un cuarto en el cual ponemos ahí
todo el equipo lo adaptamos para que te
quedes entrenes todo el día y ganamos
todos los cinturones de mexico y así
puedes llegar también a fcc y se me hizo
una idea como que si verdad si se puede
decir
y puede pensarlo porque ha tomado una
decisión pero lo platico con la almohada
y yo le digo y me dice ok no te presione
tómate tu tiempo y de todos modos ya
aquí esté gracias si tengo alguna pelea
para estos chavos que me diste su nombre
aquí
y voy lo pienso con el alma de todo y
dije si voy le práctico a mis padres a
mi familia y como siempre me apoyaron lo
mejor que ellos han podido mucho mejor
de lo que yo los he apoyado pero por eso
mismo ahora estoy dispuesto a dar lo
mejor del otro
y pues ya entonces tomé la decisión me
voy hacer varios sacrificios de verdad
corte con mi novia y luego
me fui
y pasaron algunas experiencias muy
dolorosas verdad un poco
pero ya estaba yo allí ya no había
vuelta atrás por unas experiencias que
yo tuve con unas experiencias que yo
tuve quisieran un poco dolorosas pues me
fui con mil pesos nada más y ya no tenía
boleto para mi regreso y luego ahí
tenían algo que aprender muy fuerte y
creo que sí lo aprendí bueno pues
entonces ahí es cuando yo me di cuando
el momento que yo tomo la decisión si me
voy para allá decidí perseverar voy a
perseverar pero ahí conocí a la
perseverancia en su más alto nivel en el
que me la voy a jugar a todo por el todo
yo no conozco a nadie ya no importa el
dios me va a cuidar me va a ayudar y con
las bendiciones de dios y le voy a echar
lo mejor de mí también voy a estar listo
con todo los consejos que me dé mi
familia y con eso me fui y después salió
la oportunidad de pelear a los 15 días
en brasil y yo iba con hambre y le dije
sí y peleo con los estadios ganamos y
luego de los 8 chavos que se llevaron
4 organizados no sé por qué motivos y si
van a llevar a otros 4 pero como yo
estaba alejado de brasil y luego también
y luego también este un chavo de los que
estaban allá adentro me conocía y empezó
a hablar de mí el coach también eran de
los cuatro chavales que habían llevado
entonces me llegó voy con esa beca ufc
los otros de los ocho chavos que
estábamos ahí adentro todos éramos más o
menos del peso entonces sí y ellos ya
tenían la idea de hacer un reality show
que se llama the ultimate fighter en ese
reality show es todos peleamos contra
todos en una eliminatoria y solamente va
a haber dos campeones en 135 libras y
145 libras
pues yo iba con trabajo duro trabajo
inteligente constancia y perseverancia y
gracias a dios gracias al apoyo de mi
familia y gracias a toda la gente que en
el camino me ha apoyado y que me siga
apoyando nos coronamos como campeones de
ultimate fighter latinoamérica fue
nuestros primeros y somos y de aquí la
más caliente
y
y ahora estamos en el número 13 del
mundo y tengo un sueño más grande en el
cual si dios quiere lo vamos a cumplir y
para ello poderlo cumplir tengo que ser
una mejor persona una persona íntegra
entonces si soy una mejor persona voy a
hacer un mejor peleador y si dios quiere
voy a ser el mejor peleador que pueda
hacer y si dios quiere voy a hacer el
campeón del mundo primero dios
[Aplausos]
[Música]
contras